[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous j'aurais pu être
aujourd'hui en train de construire des
aéroports controversée des ponts ou des
des édifices en tous genres et en fait
je fais totalement autre chose c'est un
peu de cette transformation que je vais
vous raconter en gros j'étais devenu
ingénieur tout départ parce que je suis
je suis ingénieur civil et je suis
devenu ingénieur parce que je rêvais
petite sphère des de construire des
ponts mais à la sortie de mes études
j'ai décidé un petit peu sur un coup de
tête
une fois en quelqu'un en stop qui m'a
bien conseillé et je suis parti faire un
tour du monde à vélo en fait voilà un
petit peu le projet qui s'est tramé à la
fin de mes études je voulais couronné
mes études et en même temps aller
chercher sur sur des thématiques qui
m'intéressait en l'occurrence
d'environnement et donc je suis parti en
en europe de l'est en turquie en iran en
asie centrale en inde en asie du sud-est
et en amérique latine
et l'idée c'était de partir à vélo donc
c'est l'idée date danse était de
favoriser les rencontres mais aussi
d'être cohérent avec le discours est
d'être économique et pendant tout le
voyage en fait de ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que on a on a déjà
découvert quelque chose en voyageant à
vélo c'est l'accueil incroyable qu'on a
eu pendant tout ce voyage en fait à peu
près trois quarts des nuits on a dormi
chez l'habitant
surtout au moyen-orient on était
accueillie très très bien tout le temps
cette culture de l'accueil en iran on a
passé un mois et demi et cinq nuits
seulement sous la tente et on s'est
rendu compte à quel point ces pays
étaient très très loin de ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer de l'image qu'on en
avait l'image médiatique et à quel point
lors la force de leur culture était bien
plus grand et l'idée d'accueillir des
voyageurs est très très forte là bas
c'était un premier choc en fait de se
rendre compte à quel point des pays qui
sont mal vues sont en fait vu par le vu
sur le terrain quand on voyage à vélo
c'est totalement autre chose le deuxième
le deuxième grand choc de ce voyage ça a
été notre sujet de recherche ça a été
les questions liées à l'environnement
on partait sur le sujet de des
consciences écologiques dans les pays
émergents et on a découvert qu'en fait
le problème était bien plus grave que ce
qu'on pensait donc déjà on a eu des
paysans andins qui nous racontait un
petit peu la problématique de la fonte
des glaciers du climat qui change depuis
à peu près dix ans et bah ils peuvent
plus anticiper les moments ils vont
avoir de l'eau les moments ils vont
avoir de la sécheresse
tout est plus accentuée à ces altitudes
là mais maintenant un peu partout mais
on a plein d'autres problèmes qui sont
liés à sa donc par exemple la pollution
la déforestation et j'en passe enfin
l'agriculture on peut encore citer et on
a je me suis peu à peu rendu compte à
quel point ceux déjà on a foncé dans un
mur au niveau civilisationnel aussi que
tout ceci était liée à notre notre envie
de contrôle du monde
en fait c'est assez marrant je me dis
que c'est peut-être un peu drôle c'est
qu'on essaie de plus en plus de
contrôler par exemple l'agriculture et
beaucoup de choses dans le monde est en
fait peu à peu tout tout c'est tous ces
aspects qu'on essaie de contrôler sont
en train de se dérégler à cause du
dérèglement climatique et il ya une donc
moi en tant qu'ingénieur vous imaginez
un petit peu en tant qu'ingénieur on est
beaucoup dans tout mettre dans des cases
et bien bien organiser les choses et là
je me rendais compte à quel point
c'était très très différents mais en
plus de ça il ya un autre phénomène qui
aggrave les choses c'est que dans
beaucoup de pays il ya cette envie de
suivre le modèle européen américain le
modèle occidental et il ya comme une
mohamed taleb tiens
un philosophe algérien explique qu'il y
à une sorte d' atrophie de l'imaginaire
depuis après à peu près quatre ou cinq
cents ans on arrive à une époque
cartésianisme donc de descartes
la raison est en fait tout doit être mis
dans une boîte où doit être mis en
équation toute chose tout problème en
fait on essaie de les résoudre dans le
dans le présent dans les choses ici et
donc on doit on doit vraiment les caser
et le problème c'est que l'imaginaire
dans tout ça à l'époque malebranche a
écrit un livre là-dessus d'ailleurs et
l'imaginaire bas il est devenu quelque
chose de mis sur le côté quelque chose
de tout petit quelque chose de voilà il
n'ya pas y'a plus vraiment d'intérêt à
l'imaginaire seulement pour quelques
petites choses par exemple ce le
divertissement ou la création pure mais
ça doit toujours servir à des intérêts
économiques à des intérêts de de
matérialité de créer du matériel et dans
le beaucoup de pays qu'on a qu'on a
traversées il ya ce que ce phénomène que
aminata traoré l'ex-miss de la culture
du mali appelle le viol de l'imaginaire
ça veut dire que les imaginaires que les
personnes avaient des cultures très
anciennes sont ont été pénétrés par cet
imaginaire de la production du
capitalisme et plus rien ne peut exister
en dehors de ça vous pouvez peut-être
leur marque et vous dans votre vie
quotidienne
et pourtant nous nous voyez on voyait à
quel point il ya aussi d'autres
alternatives qui émergeait partout dans
le monde on a des personnes qui avaient
des solutions qui était totalement dans
un autre registre et nous qui nous
touche énormément parce que ces
personnes là qu'on a interviewé elle
parlait avec le coeur elle parlait avec
les tripes elle parlait vraiment avec ce
qu'elle connaissait et avec simplicité
elle nous donner des solutions assez
assez simple assez accessible et que l
avait testé par exemple on à saïd en
iran qui nous disent eh bah moi mais
pour mes pour mes 25 ans j'aimerais
qu'au lieu de brûler 25 bougies
on plante 25 arbres ça sera d'autant
plus de choses de laisser pour les
générations à venir
on a eu aussi des 1 on a eu un paysan en
asie du sud est aussi lui pas comme
hymne peine il nous racontait qu'avant
le prenaient pour un fou quand il
plantait des arbres au milieu de ces
cultures et maintenant on l'appelle
professeur voilà on a eu beaucoup
d'expérience comme ça mario rejas aussi
un paysan du mouvement des sans terre
qui nous racontait toutes ces histoires
de lutte pour obtenir des terres et le
fait que quand il a obtenu ses terres il
a tout déforester et qu'aujourd'hui
commence à se rendre compte que il faut
faire autrement
et ici s'il avait pu faire autrement il
aurait fait autrement et nous disait ça
un gros bonhomme avec beaucoup de
charisme mais il nous expliquait à quel
point il s'était trompé et toutes ces
personnes nous parlait de petites
solutions à petite échelle mais qui
pouvait profondément apporter des choses
dans le monde
il ya aussi des communautés andines
aussi qui qui discutaient des solutions
apportées par rapport aux 10 aux
dérèglements climatiques comment
s'adapter comme ont recreusé de nouveau
des réservoirs d'eau pour avoir de la de
l'eau toute l'année parce que les
glaciers fondent et ils auront plus de
toute l'année beaucoup de choses comme
ça et il ya quelque chose qui m'a moins
marquée dans l'or dans leurs engagements
c'était tout l'enracinement qu'ils
avaient toute la conviction qu'ils
avaient est toujours en fait il était
très très très accrochés sur leur leur
culture et sur un imaginaire collectif
ou individuel qu'ils avaient peu à peu
développé
parfois des religions des spiritualités
pas toujours mais il savait un
enracinement fort et ces personnes là on
les trouve et on ne pouvait qu on ne
pouvait pas les enlever d'où elle était
elle était tellement forte dans leur
engagement que même si elle perdait des
luttes
même si elle perdait certaines choses
d'un point de vue matériel lors leur
imaginaire de ce qui pouvait être fait
était beaucoup plus grand que ça et donc
été inarrêtable
je pense par exemple à un qu'outil qui
luttait contre des projets de barrages
en asie du sud-est autour du mékong des
projets tout à fait idiot qui allait
enlever le le
le gagne-pain et toute la nourriture à
des millions de pêcheurs et lui il
disait moi c'est pas grave peut-être que
les barrages ils seront construits
mais peut-être que moi je vais continuer
à continuer à faire de l'éducation
autour de de la 2 commence nourrir
autour du mékong comment pêcher et
peut-être que dans cent ans quand les
barrages exploseront disparaîtront evans
et le peuple sera formé à ça sera encore
solide sera encore résignant et c'est
quelque chose qui nous a paru très très
important dans cette dans tout ce que
dans tout ce que les gens nous on nous
on dit c'était 7,7 force des personnes
est aussi une autonomie qui pouvait
avoir dans les choses et la convivialité
et c'est vraiment les mots qui nous sont
venus le plus en termes d'écologie
ça peut paraître un peu étrange et au
retour nous on s'est dit comment on va
transmettre ici vous avez le moment un
petit peu le retour à paris à l'endroit
puis nous on avait commencé ce tour du
monde et à ce moment là on a eu un gros
problème c'est que la plupart des gens
autour de nous et elles nous disaient
oui mais nous parler de politique en
france où nous parler de deux petites
choses ici ou nous disait c'était bien
les vacances c'était bien maintenant
pour tourner un petit peu au boulot mais
là je me suis rendu compte à quel point
mon travail mes études d'ingénieur d'un
coup ça devenait un couperet ça devenait
quelque chose qu'il fallait
enfin il fallait que je rentre dedans
c'était voilà j'avais étudié ça et il
fallait d'un coup que je devienne
ingénieur civil et moi j'avais c'est
parce que je chantais c'était parce que
j'avais envie de faire parce que j'avais
eu beaucoup de témoignages des personnes
et un moment il fallait les transmettre
il fallait j'avais j'avais une comme une
parole donnée auprès de ces personnes et
même moi j'avais une envie profonde de
transmettre ces choses aussi importantes
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait mais donc
j'ai dû renoncer à mon bon salaire
d'ingénieur à tout le confort social que
ça pouvait engendrer
j'ai dû renoncer aussi à des à une vie
sédentaire pour devenir nomades pendant
pendant cinq ans ça dure encore un peu
et donc j'ai commencé à faire des
conférences des expositions photos pour
financer
le documentaire qui est sorti deux ans
après donc beaucoup de travail sur
ordinateur vous imaginez aussi après
avoir été dans les grandes étendues
revenir en face d'un ordinateur c'est
pas facile on avait vraiment cette envie
de partager ce qu'on avait vécu et le
documentaire est sorti au bout de deux
ans on a pu le diffuser et là il ya
d'autres problématiques qui sont arrivés
à moi toujours en lien avec ce que je ce
que j'avais appris sur le terrain
en fait je me suis rendu compte que à ce
moment là jusque là en fait j'avais
laissé un petit peu tout mon imaginaire
de côté j'avais suivi une voie
d'ingénieurs et j'avais j'avais un petit
peu pompeux appauvri mon imaginaire jeu
tout à l'heure je vous parlait du viol
de l'imaginaire qui existe dans beaucoup
de pays mais en fait il a lieu aussi ici
en fait c'est dans nos écoles dans dans
quand on est jeune très souvent on nous
empêche de jusqu'à un moment nous dit
c'est génial imaginaire allez-y c'est
génial des gamins qui s'amusent mais au
bout d'un moment on dit stop
là il faut aller bosser il faut être
sérieux et on nous permet pas de peu à
peu construire autour de notre
imaginaire de construire une vie autour
de sa d'édifier autour en fait ce qui
était ce qui était des ce qui était
censé être d'aider et aider comme des
échafaudages sont devenus des prisons et
donc moi j'ai eu envie vraiment de
dépasser ça et je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à ce que ce qui écrit un autre
philosophe suisse cette fois ci
pierre-yves albrecht qui s'est beaucoup
intéressé aux phénomènes d'initiation
lui c'est quelqu'un qui a une histoire
assez particulière il s'est occupé de
jeunes drogués dans des foyers en suisse
il s'est rendu compte qu'en fait ces
jeunes 6 drogué il y avait bien une
raison je l'utilisais les drogués parce
qu'en fait je pense que on est très
drogués dans notre société à la
consommation a beaucoup de choses et
c'est son exemple est très intéressant
mais ce que lui s'est occupé de ces
drogués il s'est rendu compte que s'ils
consommaient de la drogue c'était parce
qu'il voulait atteindre incertaine il y
avait des choses qu'ils imaginaient des
choses beaucoup plus grande une image
beaucoup plus grande que même qui
voulait atteindre et la drogue un moyen
de l'atteindre très vite mais après la
descente la chute et est assez
compliquée et certains deviennent très
addict
et lui cet imac comment on va pouvoir
leur permettre de développer ces
choses-là pas leur dire mais n'en faut
pas la drogue c'est pas bien non plus
tôt comment leur permettre d'aller
d'aller vers les choses qui visait mais
de les construire peu à peu et c'est là
tout le tout le mode initiatique qui a
existé dans nombreuses sociétés qui a
toujours existé en fait chez les
amérindiens y avait il y avait ces
figures d'archétypes et puis peu à peu
on les jeunes les personnes passer des
étapes dans leur vie et c'est présent
dans le récit pour moi dans le récit
biblique dans le coran dans beaucoup de
textes en fait il ya des des textes des
mythes qui sont initiatique et la grande
question c'est de savoir aujourd'hui
pourquoi on a perdu tous et tous tout ce
chemin pour construire autour de notre
imaginaire pour l'étayer justement et
comment le retrouver et donc lui a fait
tout un tas de recherche est aujourd'hui
à une academy l'académie aurore qui
permet à des gens de suivre des
initiations mais il ya plein d'autres
initiation possible et l'important c'est
de pouvoir passer des étapes vers son
imaginaire et justement par mois c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de faire peu à peu
donc dans l'idée de construire peu à peu
quelque chose autour de ce que j'avais
appris pendant ce voyage
l'idée ça a été de construire avec une
équipe parce que forcément quand on
parle de de se construire on pourrait se
dire on va se construire tout seul mais
non l'important c'est la confrontation
aussi du regard des autres et de pouvoir
avancer dans son chemin de vie en
écrasant pas les autres tout à l'heure
je parlais domination et du problème de
contrôle qu'on avait que notre
civilisation véhiculer et 20 justement
on a tout un tout tout une quantité de
choses à déconstruire a enlevé pour
arriver peu à peu à fonctionner en
équipe et donc là c'est toute l'équipe
de l'association actuellement qui suit
le projet et on fonctionne avec des
principes sociaux pratique avec des
principes de gestion de conflits et de
quand j'oublie le mot gestion par
consentement voilà et pour avancer tous
ensemble tout en respectant les
imaginaires de chacun que chacun puisse
se sentir puisse grimper dans son dense
on danse on dans son chemin personnel en
étant respecté et je vous disais la
gestion par consentement une idée
justement de ne pas être dans le
consensus qui est la décision la plus
basse prise en fonction de tout un
groupe mais justement de prendre la
décision par consentement chacun
confronte ses points de vue on essaie de
trouver la solution la plus haute
ça c'est deux trois petits éléments
comme ça qui peuvent arriver là dedans
et l'idée l'idée c'est de se dire donc à
la fois de respecter nos imaginaires
individuelles et de les faire de leur
donner des conditions pour grandir et
aussi de permettre aux différentes
personnes qu on accompagne de dalé elle
aussi chercher leur imaginaire donc nous
on accompagne des gens d'autres gens
comme nous qui veulent voyager donc
peut-être vous demain et qui veulent
aussi faire un film partager aux à leur
retour
et l'idée c'est de les aider à
construire leur projet d'un d'un côté
audiovisuel et pouvoir au retour
partager les choses qu'ils ont vu les
différends imaginaire parce que je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de la viole des
imaginaires dans beaucoup de pays bas ce
que je veux la chose dont je me suis
rendu compte c'est qu'il fallait
valoriser de nouveau cessé imaginaire
ces cultures locales pour que de
nouvelles apparaissent dans les médias
pour que de nouveaux n'en fasse une
force
donc c'est tout tout l'idée qu'on a
qu'on a qu'on a développé et moi
aujourd'hui ça me pousse parce que bien
sûr tous tous ces médias c'est un
vecteur d'imaginaire et moi tout tout
tout ce parcours sama à la fois permis
de découvrir ce que je ce que je voulais
vraiment faire et de découvrir aux mines
est ce que mon rêve ce qui voulait dire
au départ je vous ai dit au départ que
je voulais construire des ponts et j'ai
découvert qu'en fait je voulais
construire des ponts entre les personnes
et pas des ponts physique et ça a été
tout ce toute cette toute cette aventure
tout ce tour du monde
est ce que c'est
de la construction qui s'est fait
derrière m'a permis de découvrir en fait
que plus profondément qu'elle était le
nez un peu les racines de mon imaginaire
mais il me reste encore plein de chemin
à parcourir est plein de choses à
avancer merci à vous tous d'avoir
[Applaudissements]